just like that this podcast is brought
to you by on it supplements [ __ ]
tremendo so from the strong bone to the
alpha brain go to Hana calm right now
press in charge 10% off number to listen
with C so you get unlimited access to
new Cecil original episodes the next day
late night live streaming events or
episodes your favorite classics
including 42 seasons are saying that
live Monty Python the cyanide happiness
new stand-up added weekly and more plus
uncle Joey's on seeso go to see Joe calm
right now and sign up for one month free
with promo code Joey and number two
listen to me when it comes to underwear
there's nobody nobody better than me on
these you're sitting there scratching
you had going Joey watch me undies oh
just as seriously soft feel good on
these delivered right to your door and
what I'm going to do is this you can
save time and money each month with a
monthly subscription if you're not ready
it's okay I can still save you don't go
to me on these calms last Joey that's me
on these comms last Joey get 20% off
your first pair check that [ __ ]
muley
just when you thought it was safe
[ __ ] Oh
by you bad [ __ ] Monday May 15
will the [ __ ] you think you deal with
what else what were you thinking
twisting felishj [ __ ] today it's over
for you now you were feeling down here
you go pop suckers BAM are you [ __ ]
kidding me or what you would sit there
thinking but I have a bad day your
[ __ ] mobile Uncle Joe is here George
Perez is here the flying do is here
let's do this [ __ ] what's happening
welcome to podcast Ville uncle Joey here
George Perez in the house what's up Lisa
Adam already on fire here bong just
whatever the [ __ ] you call it we were
talking about sugar daddies how hey
excuse me when I was 26 was the first
time I found out about it and like I was
in shock I felt bad for the guys like I
was hearing this from a stripper so I
was dating and she was just blabbing to
me this [ __ ] and then she told me a
story where she had a sugar daddy in
college that paid her car payment paid
her rent and little [ __ ] on fire once a
week or something like that yeah she
would bring other strippers and she'd
have to heat them in front of him he'd
go [ __ ] crazy and his parents sent
the money every week and he gave it all
to her he thought she sucked him dry
then she dumped him and he [ __ ] went
crazy you know I didn't know about this
world no I didn't know that you can then
I thought about it for years and one
night on reason I was talking about
something late-night about in Vegas like
only those girls are taken care of
that's escorts are the strippers to
these females that are just hot to some
old crazy guy oh yeah when Dan goes
listen
enough is enough you you making bad
choices and you're a lot of life you got
a job at a [ __ ] shoe store but the
whole time you got that ass and you
bring it to waste
what if yeah what if an awesome they
become Armenian what if what if I get
you a car I get your brand new apartment
I give you 2,500 cash a month but I come
over and I hit you [ __ ] with a hammer
once a month but you're on call you know
saying like I call you after church you
better be at the house 30 minutes after
I call it's not you get demoted and call
gets picked up by two out of ya
Halloween you know saying he's pure repo
and then we talk about you and the job
you used to have yeah strip club and how
crazy it gets with guys and I told you
don't I go to a strip club and I get the
[ __ ] creeps young women
yeah angry women I love all that [ __ ]
but I can they I could count on my hands
how many times I've been to a strip club
oh wow and if I go I got to go all in I
got to bring a Bucher coke yeah yeah I
got to look at your [ __ ] I gotta lick
it you know what a sucky like when I was
in a halfway house one night I went to I
got out like an 8:30 I'd have to be in
till 12:00 okay there was BYOB places
and I went along I was clean for like 90
days going to meetings and [ __ ] I had a
half ounce ago that's in his Korean
chick with fake titties and blonde
streaks there it was over Kali da a book
got lit on fire how do you get the half
ounce if you were clean and sober
because I was bringing in to sell at the
halfway house yeah I was my job I was
getting married in a month and I was
charging Vig I was selling blow I was
winning money I was a lot of bad
recognition hmm and uh yeah crazy but
besides that though one time in Vegas I
got thrown out my where we do to get
thrown about some play we got he
squatted I made a fart noise yeah
strippers go bananas yeah they don't
like those when they bend over e [ __ ] ah
ah why do I got really coked up and I
told men for the strip the pump the pump
on and she a little whiter than you ever
see a stripper with a white on their ass
I want to give her a dollar but you feel
bad you think I want that too yeah
has a hair sticking out just like
totally like a fuse no but that's it I
feel after a certain age I feel because
early on I would go to a strip little
bit that was just disgusting when I was
a kid yes it's because you feel like I
can get these girls I don't got no money
no no no I feel creepy for them which
makes me fall creepy I was talking to a
friend of mine last week about a mutual
friend that we have in Jersey and I said
to him you know for four years brother
dudes never made me feel comfortably
doesn't tell you why he's a great guy a
problem with him is he's not comfortable
his own skin okay when you're around
then you feel creepy but he's a good guy
you went to one of my comedy shows he's
the last guy expected to see it one of
my comedy shows and afterward he came up
to me and gave me a hug and he said he
was proud of me but I still went back to
the hotel scratching my head I gave her
poison on my knife I become an adult
trick on me yeah yeah that's some [ __ ]
man I mean dude like you know how you
were talking about sugar daddies like I
seen the worst case of a sugar daddy
dawg it was worser than remembering the
Harlem Nights sunshine got mad sunshine
got that cop yes
remember he caught his old lady's like a
tie your mama ain't coming home ha ha
dog so there is this old man he must
have been like 70 and he fell down in
bonds and he had a dog and like he fell
down broke his leg and he broke the
dog's legs I thought you went to the dog
dragged around her no duh so this is
crazy and he got like a five million
dollar settlement and he loved black
girls that were tatted up and looked up
to him but they had to have their own
real hair so he would come to our club
and he would spend like money until
finally this one girl came I could say
her stage name her stage name was Stacey
she was bad dog she looked like mary j
blige without talent like she was hot
pretty and she was real like she told me
she's been on ritalin ever since she was
like in tenth grade like she was just
with it so this
this old man straight up he'd give her
$1,000 these girls don't talk to no guy
in here and then she was I yelled
municipal state Oh give me 10 G's if I
[ __ ] him i [ __ ] showed up to work the
next day in the new Nissan Altima dog
like she used this guy for at least a
year $1,000 a day and he brought her
mama car and then and then it was crazy
because she would come into work
bragging she's like yeah man
the people are Bank of America were
talking [ __ ] to my man there was like
you know you don't got to buy her this
right like cuz he was pulling money out
and he had to go to the bank to pick it
up that's new style dawg
that's 300 grand a year yeah just to
just to keep her away from the other
guys yeah and and he would come in with
like it bundled because he would've wear
like these [ __ ] sweats all the way up
to his belly button and [ __ ] and then
he'd have like a big ol stack of
hundreds on the side of them and that's
that's it made me realize like man god
these girls have flipped the game
tremendous that [ __ ] makes me said it
makes me really [ __ ] emotional and
said why I know you feel bad for the man
like he knew what he was doing nah Dawg
he used to fight with her in the club
cuz like you know how you said they
don't answer all the time and she was
like one time I went to his house and it
was all dirty because you know when
you're an old man like that he had
expensive dogs and the dogs ran the
house she wouldn't clean his house for
the thousand dollars a day he'll know
that she was there to strictly jacking
off make him to give him whatever he
gave for that hour and she was gone like
she had a boyfriend I was in on it she
was buying him clothes it's like I was
just like [ __ ] I couldn't send my lady
to go [ __ ] old do to support us that's
some weird [ __ ] but yeah that's just one
of them dog I've seen guys come by girls
tits by the masses the girl that I
became tight with I was dating I got in
the middle of this because she had tried
to leave him for like two years he took
an accord oh [ __ ] so it was bad
Danny listen bro he would give him money
to go on vacation with a dude like it to
keep her hat like I've never heard this
type of stuff I had never heard this
[ __ ] before in my life nor do I want to
hear it I used to sit there and I'd be
sad and guess what
the dude started calling me Oh Javier
and at first I would hang up on him when
I was gonna little [ __ ] up I would
vote what's about it was in understand I
love my heart brother bro
I dunno type of guy in my mouth bro he's
like Al I said - how can you love her
what she was dating all these dudes and
you're just milking her knee she knowing
he tried it they know it they want the
feeling I couldn't be mad at her
listen I'm a thief no matter what you're
doing you're still a thief at the end of
the day yeah I couldn't be mad at her
they gave her an opportunity she used
her gifts and this guy boy I mean was
the same thing you even I can't remember
half the [ __ ] I don't wanna tell
something that's wrong vacations I love
all that she went to the Bahamas with a
dude and then she said she was staying
for three days she stays for five dude
showed up oh wow gave the dude money
like a thousand bucks to get back on the
plane with her man I said to him gotta
play you know [ __ ] like that Wow I at
the end of the week you sit down yo
Jesus Christ but his father died left
that money same thing so the mother gave
him an allowance of like 20 grand a week
and she would get 18 of it damn she's
treacherous yeah I told you right after
I David she started dating an Indian guy
and he hate that stuff like 78 years old
didn't get a hard-on no more he died
like the [ __ ] dude in Dallas with the
[ __ ] chick with the big tits and died
from death and in a call the same thing
yeah that was 30 something years old she
marries a hearse every son near old dude
you know and then she turned it over she
flipped it and she kept doing it but
they either that's it those three years
I was with and I was
worse luck bro I ever had in my life but
yeah she was surrounded by bad luck and
if you ever work with strippers which
you did [ __ ] when they walk in they all
got a story
oh my follow up my building burned down
my sister got shot they all got a story
because a part of what they do is what I
was doing with a gun
mm-hmm and what I was doing why the
people is the same thing yeah it does
nothing different no matter how I look
at it but it was a different style
flexible they got the wager man like
they got the [ __ ] and and you know
going back to this guy that your girl
Carol's with yeah like I noticed these
guys they kind of like that power he was
she was 24 he was doing this from the
age of 20 to 24 25 ah
but for like the years she tried to cut
it all I think she would give him some
money back like a grand oh [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah cuz she wanted been that 8 grand
how to give back was hard
she's my little girl's brother she has
30 if she has three thousand and three
dollars showing for those three dollars
but she'll starve and won't touch two
three why I've never seen anything like
this
well you guys I know duh like the whole
like there's a whole bug thing now on
Instagram of just Instagram models who
just are some hound traveling the world
and yeah it's sugar daddies are taking
care of everything
everything you know like and there's
even sugar mamas out there man there's
older women that if you young and you
win it they gonna hook you up
it's crazy I had one once but you know
she was I was getting like looking like
80 a week he's got about excel just was
low you over the bottom ever Union you
would apprentice package you can't get
your card for four years [ __ ] you gotta
find out that listen that no that should
have been happening man I have no sure
the moms
nothing every loan every loan I took I
had to pay back yeah where's of it but I
just went Carol was filling me in on
this the first time guys I was dying
yeah I mean did it hurt you dog like did
you ask for any does he do what I do to
you like I don't know I'm not one of
those guys that you open yeah I did that
when I was 22 Domino's are a complete
can of work you don't want to know where
they've been
yeah no I know as soon as I start
telling me you go listen up yeah I'm out
give me a G I'm Adam I love you I don't
care you got gang bangs what he able to
do he with 28 huh
hopefully by now you push it all the
juices out of that definitely we can
have a child you know I don't like
ovaries god hey but you know you were
talking about pimps is a check this out
man
I stopped DJing at a strip club like
about a year ago and I remember the new
thing is is pimps they now make their
prostitutes go work at the strip club
because they're like you know what
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're going to go in
there and you're going to give me all
the money you make from there and it's
weird because like the strip club I was
at it had a whole stroll in the front
like there was prosecutes walk in the
street and then we were their
competition it was like hey you want to
be safe if you know what I mean and dude
I I only know this because one girl was
like a man look call the cops
my boyfriend's waiting out there and if
I don't come out with the money he
thinks I got I'm going to get my ass
kicked I'm sick of this [ __ ]
like what they do is they have kids with
these chicks and then they got the kid
waiting for him back in the hotel room
she's like I already had my sister pick
up my son nah we like it was crazy
though it was like an escape and that's
what was outside just looking like
yellow man is she and then I was like
yeah dog when she's getting ready he was
like well I do I need to get her and all
right
so to drink minimum go right that can
tell you Miller [ __ ] it
a dog it's it's crazy like that that
that pimping and stripping game is
getting too comfortable with each
you know what I mean it's like there
used to be a lot of fine line or was
just like you know what you're going to
get from either spot now they're trying
to coexist with each other
I learned something at the age of 16
that most men will never learn their
life I learned that the age of 16 until
this day I'm very grateful when I played
CYO ball in the 8th grade
it was a dude that went at it it was
maybe three years old I was and I'd be
sad they we go down to practice and then
you could stay for two hours and shoot
hoops and everybody was allowed that
kids last name was BS come on remember
his first name was only we went to visit
my mother's grave
right that's how I look I look for my
mother's grave once I find him mm-hmm if
I stayed horizontally I'd bump into
another second cousin of mine oh who
jumped off the bridge we were related
through dad's like my dad when I think
all the mangoes feed bancini
okay this kid's name is Jorge Hernandez
he was beautiful from Union City New
Jersey he played football but he had a
problem eh
Wow an occasional college now and he had
a bunch of dilemmas so once I see those
two I know my mother's two or three rows
away okay cuz they each died like June
July things I know but that's how they
lay him out yeah but that kid Mario Diaz
although Mario Diaz was the Karate Kid
different he was Chinese Cuba this kid
dear he's hoping the Karate Kid he was
very nice bro when I was in that kid
that you know when you're 14 and you
hang out with somebody who's 17 and they
having sex it's pretty impressionable
yeah well maybe he was 16 but I mean he
had stories every [ __ ] Saturday and
he had three dudes with him and those
days if he was 16 and you dress up
George then they enter bars or near the
city oh yeah yeah they like into 3 a.m.
well they even go to a city in those
one man a fake ID which cost you $6 and
42nd Street you did whatever the [ __ ]
you want it you had it in those days
they had a cover at the door they
understood you hadn't understand it when
I was here I'm gonna let you in there
you're sixteen you [ __ ] up when the cops
come I don't have your back and you hand
them back in here ever again so you had
to act on your best behavior so in those
days if you dressed up your shoes behind
you didn't act like an [ __ ] you had a
little bit of a mustache sixteen did my
chin because the drinking age was 18
yeah
so it didn't really matter yeah he
looked 18 you know yeah he had an ID
[ __ ] you there was no scanners none of
the [ __ ] they got now they try to [ __ ]
with you and ask you a horoscope like
what's your horoscope you know [ __ ] like
that nothing you haven't memorized all
that all that memorized but by the time
I was fifteen and a half there was a guy
my labor names weak mr. combs weak and
some buddies he gave somebody his
license and that dude gave it to me okay
and if in those days Jersey it didn't
have a picture no I was hitting me blood
type you want to donate your eyes you
know [ __ ] it your name your address your
zip code and the number your license how
do they get away with that no man I
changed it afterwards New Jersey never
had a picture after immigration that I
know any pictures I like some somebody
showed up with a big envelope and
silligan no pictures no pictures so we
got 40 minutes so [ __ ] we got three
days to the NCIC comes back and we can
bail you out seeing those day is the
NCIC then come back for 72 hours George
well now so if you want a national level
and you knew it so he's got arrested you
well they're waiting for me by the time
they got the paperwork back to those
facts reason by the time I went to
Washington and they ran it and unless
you a priority or something that's a
sack of papers that's two days so I time
you get back like one time I got a
misdemeanor thing like gave a fake name
I bailed that I went to court when I got
back for years every time I listen to my
court file and showed that court case I
was like damn they could have arrested
me never arrested me because when I tell
the fingerprints on misdemeanors took a
year for your fingerprints to come back
they went to the bottom of the bottle
then I had not much money in those
departments either all that that's what
they did on Saturdays and Sundays all
overtime three weeks in crystal Minas
felonies had the first bucket I bought
yeah no but that whole world joins as
always it's made me kind of sad and it
does and then like I said to you I love
to see women naked you know Megos not
wrong with everyone anybody else you
want to put that monk Wong on my face if
it opens up my sinuses we're in business
you know say if I could sniff that
monkey nut it's a joke but whenever I go
to a strip club especially after the way
quick [ __ ] thirties I always got
creepy but I always got the creeps
that's why I stopped going I didn't see
the sense of it you know I've never been
maybe I went to a Dee's place one time
with Rogan all the way by the airport
they shot a bunch of movies and it was
really pretty in there Rob got three
floors oh wow
two floors that's the baller the first
floor they dance the second floor come
as you want you don't saying do what you
need to do mentally those nuttin no
cameras a timer goes off yeah that's it
exactly
egg is boiled once the timer goes off
the egg is [ __ ] boy that cutting open
after that but I always felt when I was
young had a bad experience I was oh God
in home braum Catholic I thought love
was love yeah you know at that time I
had a seventh grade girl who told me she
loved me and we were gonna [ __ ] in July
when school was over so the whole year
she had been a drive up mission just
wide open waiting for them closely in
your life
has she reneged on me that kill me ah
you know saying like it just kill me and
then
my friend has Pablo Obregon God rest his
soul
he took me into the city one night with
his [ __ ] candy truck his father had a
candy company and at night he steal his
father's truck we'd be in the back of
the thing why does she bars and [ __ ]
potato chips and pretzels
don't touch the pretzels there for
[ __ ] so the VC went to at 10:40 Club
and it was all his $10 $9.99 a bush tax
1040 of 1980 yeah he would go there
every week so you wanted to bring us
like this is my favorite place what's
the value of 10 bucks in those days that
cut is like 50 now 20 now maybe 42 okay
disgusting there's no value there's
somebody who sells you their [ __ ] from
99 cents okay there's no value that
[ __ ] comes with disease an itch yeah
lifestyle yeah a lifetime of [ __ ]
flashbacks nothing in that room is good
for you
till that's this day that feeling never
went away from me George
yeah that creepy feeling of walking back
there because the back of my mind I
believe and flowers and chocolate
cauldrons in [ __ ] and I came in a minute
that I go what what's the use of buying
chocolate north of the stall as longer
than me coming in a [ __ ] midnight
there's no rubbing neck sometimes you
rub my neck I come in my bed I I come
from eating [ __ ] sometimes that's how
quick I am I just pass out my boobs
laughs nothing is mine later my [ __ ]
legs
crazy glued to the [ __ ] of linoleum
just I'm eating out then sometimes I
just get so excited I get anxiety I just
crack a nut and there's some crazy
fetishes in anal strip club man the you
know what the craziest [ __ ] to Joey is
the [ __ ] fight in there because a
gripper dressing room is equivalent to a
prison yard they separate in groups
the old ones kid with the old ones the
black figure the blacks the lands and
the whites is intermixed they never got
the own group
I don't know why they just end it's like
you got the pill poppers the cokehead
girls and when they fight it's like to
die like we have to jump in like dude
slide Tommy at the strip club he was at
that they had to carry a girl on a
stretcher what are they fighting about
just [ __ ] you think you got you're
gonna remember a strippers kind of like
a it's a boy she's a bully a stripper
someone that school swaggin if they want
to show these other [ __ ] they need to
be [ __ ] with
so weird like when I when I used to walk
back there I felt like a cop for the
first time because I they would all hide
all their [ __ ] like they got [ __ ] going
on in there that's ridiculous and April
you called out the best a thief is
always a thief so they still from each
other crazy and there's cameras
everywhere so local call it you know
what I was gone at this time and that
time to go to the manager I'm gonna get
the camera sure enough that [ __ ] stole
my [ __ ] and it's like superfight I've
seen some crazy fights it's uh it's
insane you know to see beautiful naked
women fighting each other do they fight
about like is that only a good spot look
at how and calmly there's the headliners
they're like a good they don't oh yeah
if you try to bump a [ __ ] you're going
to get [ __ ] up if you're next and this
other girl comes she goes hey you know I
want to go before her goes like now
[ __ ] I'm next like or my customers here
like like they'll fight over customers
that I hey you know what that guy spends
money put me on stage and they're like
oh it was my I'm scheduled for this time
no it's not scheduled time it's you have
them on a roll sheet so like say destiny
comes in dynasty Porsche you write their
names down on the list once you start
bringing girls onstage you got a goal by
the girls like the order and there's no
break songs it's like if I'm DJing and
Aerosmith splain I just turn it down for
a second all right guys give it up right
there for destiny we got fly girl up
next and once that once that songs
changed that other girl has to get her
money get our ass off stage and the next
girl goes leave there's no wrong
answer is no wrong answers we'll ask you
a question okay what is the motor of
what is the motive right of an exotic
dancer to make money okay so what is the
rule of making money
showers gang on stage and telling
herself in her world what is the route
of making money being on stage in George
what's the root of a Reagan really
[ __ ] getting customers showing off
your everything you're running yeah
she's as healthy yeah exactly salesman
to the master sound sure thick me said
Joey listen to me
the stripper is a car salesman only who
shows that to their [ __ ] they have a
kid at the house the old man left them
he's doing time you know what man it's
expensive the time it exists it's
expensive for a thousand tents you have
to make money you have to make
limitations you have a child at the
house your bills you have two kids you
try to put fool you know what's rent
what's rent when you have two kids yeah
what's childcare what's a car what's so
if a [ __ ] girl is smart she's a sales
girl who makes the most money George the
one who puts the titties on the Lupus a
cat for skirt on with the Sun with the
glasses with little titties with nice
shoes on the walks out there and you
know she's a dirty [ __ ] animals right
uh no that's the one you look for that's
the one you avoid the one with the
Catholics with the stockings that's got
glasses on she looks like she's too
pretty to be in the joint yeah she's a
savage yeah but she gets on top of you
laughs you get your dick hard then she
start becoming a pickpocket
that's what Houdini goes to work oh my
god you dick hard okay that's their job
what's they get that good that's what it
because $1,000 a day plus a bag of blow
even so what if they give a [ __ ]
it must be amazing just because like
that because I had a car buying
experiences past couple weekends and
they always make you feel like they're
your best friend
oh yeah it's amazing good like that what
if they're gonna grab your dick or show
you their tails and there's a list of
George how do you so blow George go
where you locate this George come here
person come in the coalition us here
Isabel don't ask a broader show on
Netflix yeah the dude that he was
hanging out with his nephews nephew the
best for me since I go they just gave me
a [ __ ] kilo and his coach it's
tremendous it's a diagram it's
tremendous it anything percent no yeah I
call you into a corner put two [ __ ]
spoons in your nose straight let's see
you turned pale that's in you all the
money comes out of your pocket there's
money telling the cocaine world we money
talks and [ __ ] water right there
somebody gives me the rockatuer bulb i
turn to you only go away what's in your
pocket oh well I'm holding on formal
even parley give me the money I'll stab
me the [ __ ] next block will buy this
guy how much with a laptop but I make an
offer he can't refuse
and you know what to go with joy you
know what's what laptop only give the
last up executive gotta give the
backpack the whole [ __ ] hahaha but
Joey I don't want to go to peace don't
matter some babies get a spoon does blow
over the head twenty years and you know
what's weird too is we have to fight the
customers off dog because they're all
constantly trying to bring that [ __ ] in
to calm the girls and to not giving them
money because you know they pay cheaper
for the drug so the girl would give a
hundred bucks for two grams where they
only pay forty and now the girls like
like go lie to us all that guy never pay
me why don't you tell us does you guys
see who's going to his car so now she
played us she got her sack and now we
can't get our cut of them it's so crazy
dog I trip out and then now there's a
new website I guess where the customers
judge the girls I didn't tell you how
good the dances are they yelled first
covers night yeah I'll - I'll text it to
you tomorrow cuz some of the girls that
I used to work with they'd always be
like look at this like other girls would
fake like there were customers and make
a bad comment about a girl that's making
money to [ __ ] her up it's a dog-eat-dog
a dog-eat-dog world
yeah
it's crazy yeah it's and some of them
work in packs perfect dog they work in
packs because Carol used to work anyway
apart like a lion pack so they work
together yeah and they work like Bing
Crosby and [ __ ] Bob Hope Jack they
work you take a [ __ ] bird and from
you Kevin McHale they're like clapping
Jack and Coke
yeah acting Kobe it's a [ __ ] one and
if they're both good-looking it's over
off one is black yeah watch the other
ones white the other one is latina and
they both come to the same cut that they
need 1,200 if you feed that kid smoke
and drive their [ __ ] Porsche they're
making 1,200 that day this guy just
offices 5000 go back to this hotel yeah
don't when you need 7,500 and you want
5,000 up front I mean these girls are
[ __ ] sales women you know I need to
see the cash right now 5,000 up front
honey before I go anywhere give him the
money and don't so give me my 2,500 but
you just said 5,000 and next thing
they're gonna find out and they're
eating each other out can you the deal
telling you the [ __ ] deal it is dying
I'm telling you I was with Carol for
four years and it was on and off but it
was always a story I always had to go
for an AIDS test
yeah no I've been there guys a year
because I didn't trust it at all
and then we broke up and we stayed
friends eat and then you know we just
talked and one day I told the one I felt
and she agreed and that was its result
she's always been honest with me said
that she's had men to live in the house
and whole thing and it's three nights a
week she down there I love good that
she's a great - yeah it's a hustle to me
is that but it's interesting to see at
the hustle never went away I keep a chef
you have no she's 40
seven if I'm 54 yes she's about 47 46
even though she has a full-time job that
pays of a benefit I think she still
dries out there twice a [ __ ] month
mmm-hmm did I've met some crazy girls
right we had this fine older lady her
stage name is Danielle and her husband
was I think he was like game unit and
they were married for 25 years and she
found out that he was cheating on her
for 12 years she [ __ ] got half the
money and she said I've always wanted to
be a stripper now she's a stripper dude
fine oh she's about 45 fine because all
she did was work out like I never had
kids with them he was never home but he
was cheating on her and yeah my xbox was
crazy Joey she was like a 52 year old
lady and she was beautiful she had the
best [ __ ] [ __ ] in the world that she
would show it off to us if she would
show his picture she's like look
[ __ ] that pussy's ta-da'-da any
girls [ __ ] in here and I was like
that's you dude she has pictures of her
whip I bet you you know her I bet you
you know look Italy well like I let
somatically you haven't [ __ ] you're a
national hero that's my old boss like we
all talk about it baby she cares your
old boss huh no she's my old boss that's
crazy I like she's beautiful dog she's
52 and like I would have [ __ ] her but
I was scared she always wanted to [ __ ]
me but I was scared because everybody
she [ __ ] at work ended up getting
fired like about eight months later
she'd always [ __ ] the youngsters and she
liked me because her ex her ex-husband
was a chola like me and she this girl
had she reminded me of you joy but she
had stories and she knew her [ __ ] was
power she quit because she married a
millionaire straight up
cruise by work in a Tesla [ __ ] you guys
no [ __ ] dude she's with it and and at
the club I was working at she used to be
a dancer there and they she ended up
getting lupus
she had to quit and the customers are
like well how are we going to see you
she became the manager and just started
like telling the customers I can't dance
for you but I'll do things and dog
baller baller like she told me that she
went to Tokyo to strip for five years
she made like three hundred dollars in
there she's just straight balling why
the black/white beautiful she looked
like um [ __ ] who's that girl in Scarface
the one Tony was in love with the show
fun she looked like Michelle Pfeiffer
right before she did the movie as a
substitute teacher she looked good and
that fifty her ass looked like she was a
gymnast yeah with it it's funny because
the way I was raised and the whole thing
well okay so I was 21 and I said this on
the show before I lived in Aspen
Colorado
ah and that's the first time I suspected
something that's the first time I'd be
at a Chinese restaurant they the one the
only one of that that was horrific by
the way at that time horrific how do you
get Chinese in Colorado horrific and
I'll never forget the first time I saw
and we pulled though because I lived in
Basalt which is a dirty mouth South so
on a special occasion we do I love to
Aspen bark to : Walker was in 1983
George yeah and this is Aspen there's a
popular place they got Italian there
this man had Chinese I forgot what the
name was we walked in there Oh God from
New York City yes I was saying like
isn't that known for Chinese food New
York oh yeah also come 1920 and I'm
walking into this Chinese restaurant
expecting New York City food and I
nearly [ __ ] puke guys that was the
first time like my heart stopped Chinese
was a [ __ ] is that one of the places
that you had under your under your
control perfume no no I never went back
there I think I went once again one
and I gave it another shot like 18
months later and it was still horrific
you got locked up in Denver honk all
right over there yeah got lost us who's
Aspen life Georgia what's the difference
between ads like the rich area yes for
hours
Oh away Aspen at the time was where the
he was lived Oh to live a little one
time Jonathan all of those [ __ ]
animals
I still wear my shirt like that guy who
live out there and it was very peaceful
the airport wasn't little planes only
good land there from Denver that a lot
of charter lands it was a very big drug
town it was a lot of drugs up there oh
yeah I moved to basalt I'm 1819 you know
I'm clean for a month
I never even dared of asking I was happy
chilly uh-huh I was happy to have it
around me for the first time I was gonna
try to really go without it within two
weeks the people is living check was
talking about and my roommate started
talking about it with everyone and I
still played it cool but then we broke
up and I had to move up to pass lomez
village and three days after I'd just
never let somebody as I don't like owed
and it was [ __ ] tremendous it's good
huh [ __ ] off the rattles up so I
started just buying a half a gram every
Friday I'd paint my little salad I
always made ones lettuce tomato onion
with Oscar Mayer salami
I thought we deal with any longer
vinaigrette heavy with the red pepper
and I would [ __ ] hate that and then I
had like six beers can I'd watch us a
nice light mmm I take the coke and cut
up into little lines like sit there and
I'm right little [ __ ] stupid things
then I go my room and bang one out
and coke and for example potatoes oh but
you have to when you're on some good
coke that like it
good cocaine makes you like into a
[ __ ] bartender you know I want to
Keela know I want want you know I want
to talk in and then you try to eat in
it's the worst you know if you're
ignored as those days I still wonder
then will you enjoyed oh I got any
you're experimenting right is only I
would start at ten and by 3:00 3:30 I
then did go to the room
jerk off again go to bed and the next
day it was forgot yeah that was it I'm
not going public in those days okay I
knew people who got hired to house and
when they said to myself that's what
I'll do
no going out I don't want nobody to see
me coked up yeah I used to be like that
like you turn it to your own spy
I used to lock my dog in the other room
so here oh no no no no this is early on
I was doing this later on and I know
you're talking [ __ ] that's it you can't
go out loud I'm talking about early on I
had this thing there's a lot of people
if I went out and saw people join I
would lose my mind I go dog get the [ __ ]
outta here like I always had something
against that and don't make me get
started from where I know what you're
gonna do is seven these people have
rings around their little like that used
to drive me crazy cuz ever people close
to me like my mom okay I'll have to tell
my mom oily pathology about a half wipe
your [ __ ] nose then in the mid
eighties that things started with people
George what people's Joel is it because
they cut it with different stuff it was
still powerful like your [ __ ] head
would get numb in 82 the cope was
completely different than when it became
an 87 cleaner 82 yeah I'm gonna go to
Miami Joy's can eighty four five get
nothing playing and doing some [ __ ] that
your eyes would get ready
like the veins in your eyes or get all
by your go to Memphis the brothers and
Memphis their eyes all beady and [ __ ] by
performance or look nervous
that's how eyeballs get your red
eyeballs and [ __ ]
yeah head gets hot but you'd think would
get hard yeah you wouldn't get paranoid
you get real thirsty for alcohol and you
were but who stages that's what people
never understand that the addiction has
stated I started in 79 and until 84 83 I
didn't get creepy I know exactly social
first four years it was a party I can go
to a bar [ __ ] with George I don't go to
work another whiskey tonic
it was very social then I would bring it
back to wherever I lived and get high
and back out and bring a girl back and
snort coke and put him in a bikini with
heels and you know crazy
you know you get [ __ ] crazy in those
days there was no condoms
there was nothing you didn't give a [ __ ]
I think they work on them no not till 85
till Rock Hudson came out and talked
about AIDS is that when the condom was
imagine know what the cousin was always
around when I was the top was better
Howard again because when I was this
fifth grade that summer I robbed a box
of condoms green a bunch of it from a
back of a [ __ ] like a pharmacy and
you see the German all day man look at
so yeah again from a pharmacy a pharmacy
in those days we were walking you know
the parking not what kid dog yeah fifth
grade fourth grade summer you know
[ __ ] walking we just went to Carvel
we got ice cream we're walking in a
parking lot and there's a truck and the
back is wide open and next with the
stacks of boxes and we searched
right there and all of a sudden bro we
saw that the guy would take one box at a
time and go in so we supposed take a box
each then we all went over and took a
box and just taught we just ran hair
yeah we got the light the light was
green we crossed Kennedy Boulevard down
to [ __ ] the Chinese store know this
music order Ching store and we can the
dragon grocery aka the Ching store on
Sundays it was a bodega
the old man was cool as [ __ ] the dog was
a [ __ ] the dog was the first Lucy Liu
oh it was 1979 nobody was looking for
losing yeah nobody gave us but 1975 it
had to be a words when we stole those
comes because we were nobody was even
thinking the [ __ ] and I stole those
comments the whole crew I hung out with
nobody was [ __ ] people kind of
talking about it somebody made out
somebody touch somebody's teddy and
nobody was [ __ ] out of all the boxes
the six of us took one guy got like
cream for your hands one guy got like
[ __ ] hair pins yeah is what I
remember I never forget that happened
what the [ __ ] ammonia dirty happens and
I got a box of comes and the only came a
woman color oh yeah black now share they
were thick and house I was black so I
sold what I could for 50 cents well he's
gonna come yeah good value in those days
if you had a condom in your wallet you
this [ __ ] yeah what was your sales pitch
yeah
how can you come in what happens if you
bump into a [ __ ] hot chick and you
finger did that awesome yeah
11 you saying this oh yeah we're just
[ __ ] with people which was we took
them to the Chinese bodega he bought
like three boxes but I don't want stars
down I don't know yeah that's fine I
will hang out cuz he was Chinese Cuban
so whenever he was saying Spanish he'd
say knees first and translate it and
then say it in Spanish
cool this [ __ ] and we sold half of them
we just went to dirty a street punk and
broke him out so I'm gonna forget I had
that I can't even reuse a wallet who
made condoms back there was a Trojan or
a good year bootleg condoms I don't
[ __ ] know like how much far me from
the salami I don't know that [ __ ] good
news remember everything else is good
you [ __ ] damn track that was before
the middleman you took him before they
put the package on a problem raising the
hand crazy dog we were young young
nobody got laid that condom okay how
long yeah
I still remember what I busted that
condom out with and it was dry uh Adam
was disintegrate fire yeah yeah although
that thing expired
eight times by the time I was located I
just put it in there raw I didn't give a
[ __ ] those yeah I was like in the
[ __ ] my sophomore year my G that's
right I met this girl in one Bergin pool
she was a year older but yeah I swear to
god she's not very good we started
talking [ __ ]
you forgot the pool no don't I got
manners I'm a Catholic
I took a total movie I bought a popcorn
Zack and we swap spit and then I would
go uptown and go it's like not enemy
territory but it was not the friendliest
territory yeah neutral I would knock on
her door
I was already in high school when I was
in enemy territory or neutral territory
because it was a different nation
neighborhood and then when they I'm
walking home and I see some dude from
that territories like coca-cola so I
walk a home I swamps play with her well
when I see the kid goes did you [ __ ] her
already and I go now what he's talking
to my gos huh I check his [ __ ] like 10
guys ah it was over I just told her
right I don't listen I think it's gonna
get shaken he had and warm Rodriguez God
rest his soul solid soul job I said you
gotta bring a friend and she brought a
friend and with the warm with Ria's his
house his parents worked in Goa in fact
the way every time I do Miami his other
brother Carlos comes to the show that's
crazy I was just thinking
cause DNA you know what's crazy think
face looks purple dog is that the light
or into this nest are you mr. death sir
I guess so this is sorry I'm sure no
it's a Death Star is purple so the ink
from the Death Star is golden tea
eyeballs right now so right now I just
saw streaks of purple to it yeah it's
like yeah the face is not you see little
stars it's all right no bro I had sex
with this girl I kind of I really liked
it it's something happened like I don't
know but it wasn't good sex alone I was
doing I was young and nervous and clumsy
she was beautiful
who knows what the hell happened but
limitation I met one first because one
used to date a chick by my not-so I was
cool possibly face to train with her and
her girlfriend once the guy that you
seen walking home that told you about it
right about what warned about that girl
[ __ ] tank is done the wall thank you Ben
kid that was from Pennsauken New Jersey
ruff-ruff shitty outside of Philadelphia
and candid but he was white but he
played basketball he was black okay he
was five foot six George his shake was
lethal because he was close to the floor
you don't say yeah he shook you if you
wanna be with dawn yeah he would just
burn you on the left hand side and then
he would do a bunch of [ __ ] in the side
and foul and one he was all-county
freshman year so he had a younger
brother and one part of his hair in the
middle and combed it this way like a
shag they called it seven days but
Carlos called this straight back and he
had a widow's peak I was plays
basketball too and he was on the
freshman basketball thing so four months
every time I'd see Carlos Lee I knew
cause when he was older brother I went
to his house I had sex with a kid on his
bed you know every kind of fact like I
said Carlos just went to one of my
shelves look
Miami ok I see Carlos got called him
Jack because Iran pyre yeah and he take
Joey Coco please don't call me drag
through this [ __ ] corner on and
basketball practice I just haven't had
sir least I called a drag drag drag get
pissed off see Coco what you started
[ __ ] [ __ ] and he would go back to his
room so now it's a Christmas tournament
in East Orange New Jersey know what that
means we're going into all black
territory okay that means we'll go on
into all-black territorially other asses
handed to us
yeah freshman year basketball we got on
the bus we get out there
we're playing this [ __ ] Christmas all
of it and the next thing you know one is
a guard he's just starting got a comma
there more to it it's like wow this is
freshman brush wing year okay cuz it'll
be refreshment and Carlos's taking the
ball out of mallet him he hated that
direction so right before the referee
gave the ball a black kid looked at him
is here outdoor I can't be Hadj it
because that's how I learned comedy I
saw comedy for reals I saw this black
guy walked up to take a look at and also
he goes yo yo to his partner he goes
look at my dog over here he was like any
monsters [ __ ] bro that dude [ __ ] think
when they do the ball at him he just sat
there he was cracked I know look around
don't guess what happens he they said
that too and he what we didn't say a
word we just every other team saw that
he fries he could play the rest of the
game he was flustered [ __ ] and the next
thing you know on the bus I have to
about 20 minutes people just started
calling him Eddie Munster Oh until today
people still that dull because that
gnome like really don't still go and he
wants to list a deal with Neil
just looking you know what the [ __ ] well
how do you still remember that [ __ ] with
Tony Bennett [ __ ] Tony ban it
surprised you didn't end up in like a
mental hospital
oh my god so cool phrase a restroom I
wanna be ticketed in the area doc I'm
drinking wine in some pottery somebody
somebody who will swear to be true as
you used to do with I'm on my internal
cooking [ __ ]
Stoli whose edibles on 5c oh yeah eight
thousand else do you know it's a buffet
nice I told you that I love buffet uncle
I resent to something I come say with
that Thank You Larry
inside look Larry always comes through
oh you guys are knock over here the
office door some guy comes in befriend
the Larry's ah your old name and pitbull
misses you
who pitbull I think you might need to
move back into his net back into his
district he misses you a lot
I stopped him today he said I saw your
day no he didn't say that he said then I
went back to the mail about you know the
other I said doors yes and I told you
I'm gonna take a piss on the freeway on
the way here you're crazy [ __ ] men
judging a little doctor he gets a get
Sharon yeah she's another movie about
Mexico colonel we gonna come back for
the fourth of July whatever whatever the
[ __ ] down bro yeah yes like that today
Mexico hooks you up my Cuba yeah I think
I don't thank you I think Mexico might
have free I think it anything else can
you go to villages Vanille are you sure
I don't know if it's free but I think I
think it's cheaper and then I don't know
how good it is
well gotta do what the [ __ ] am I said I
think I'm here loss I know that for a
fact that a friend of a friends which I
helped out said that he needed donations
if I don't think I even tweeze that
cancer but what he was doing was he was
going to Mexico when the medical
treatment is five times cheaper and it's
in a way it's even better than here his
cancer was cured he came back he's right
my sickle again everybody's happy
I could just imagine that being oh yeah
a lot of people go down if I
printed yeah but they get screwed yeah
yeah yeah be careful it's not [ __ ] uh
what's his name what's the black name
you said before the convenient which fly
off you lie down there make it believe
me Mexican it's a job and she shoot you
with fentanyl Michael Jackson juice
whatever the [ __ ] they shoot now there
is this stripper that was well they know
that I don't know Jackson juice yeah but
I should that should blowing up right
now yeah it it's weird like how do you
overdose what the [ __ ] doctor giving
it to you some weird [ __ ] like it went
over well he was on any [ __ ] things
what kills me about the drug world which
family I live you I was a part of I
should have stopped snorting coke when
Lenny bias I know so this day I always
go I'll never forget that morning that
he died I was waking up from a [ __ ]
blizzard you know sorry I know exactly I
said I was waking up from a [ __ ] to
bang a day with three cases of being I
had a shop of whiskey and [ __ ] people
why this painting your chats from all
the cigarettes he smoked I didn't smoke
at that time is so life is love weed at
that time only and I would drink
it's gonna blow and in those days if you
had something to those days quaaludes
astora
you know what that's thinking to come
back I heard what Quayle a movie I see
you know why because of the Cosby thing
exactly um I never understood that
like the first marketing that I ran into
like that that made me laugh was in the
old days in New York they would sell
Nickelback you know in some weed was ten
bucks they would tell you this from Cali
or it's Thai weed and you would pay the
ten it was three or four joints but then
earlier people go got tens cuz I got
trays what's a tray 920
a $3 bag $3 bags a $3 bag and it was
angel dust
oh and so that's like one hit it would
know the $3 bag you roll it like you
regularly to roll enjoy and recklessly
ready village of the joint Jorge I take
like a cigarette thing and my school put
into the joy I done little joy
we have probably have a good joint and
maybe another half a joint here or we
could just be savages you and I bought a
whole [ __ ] sin here ten out of ten I
poured the whole [ __ ] ticket you know
I roll you notice he scratched his face
oh my god right well orrible it was
[ __ ] horrible was horrible it was a
night I would do it I was just writing
about this today like it you know George
what was afoot how were you the first
time you put some money of those you
know what I got peer pressured my
sophomore year it was speed but it was
crank it was [ __ ] it it made my [ __ ]
brain like it went straight for my nose
and like I felt like somebody was
[ __ ] jabbing chopsticks in my [ __ ]
brain and my eye in the back here hurt
oh my god you know speed is different
from coke coke is like a good fellow and
you do speed it's like automatic like
sharp [ __ ] pain to your brain first
time I did speed I just robbed that Bank
place all weekend I had a [ __ ] drawer
full of twenties I'm a [ __ ] high
school of a sophomore in high school
maybe a junior and I missed Christmas my
first Christmas without my mother oh
[ __ ] yeah you're mad Alton I started
going that strip club with women would
sit on bottles and [ __ ] oh and why can't
I my wet dog openly some people like
this if you want a girl the back is
twenty bucks if you want to buy some
drugs see that girl over here like a
listen about
on the back what we're gonna show you
over I'm a [ __ ] kid George how sad is
that
yeah I may be 17 I got 250 over me 280
and I go see the girls because you want
to get it on my girl oh yeah yeah but
how my god first I go what do you got
then she doesn't had 22 coke like a
grands the speed and I gotta go to Spain
thought I was a couple days away from
president Christmas it was a couple days
Oh have you had money so I go what do
you got she goes to the speed is 80
I got twenties I'm gonna give me an 80
in two twenties I took that [ __ ]
eight he puts in my top pocket took
those two twenties I gave him fifty for
the girl
it was the nastiest lap dance ever if I
was telling I was done by this time the
experience of the city with the [ __ ]
chickens at ten forty club when she's
gone taught me squeaking and they become
squeaking Oh gross time wasn't she goes
you know for next to ten dollars you can
eat me don't miss hot little these are
things that have to be early on that
destroyed my insides because don't like
I told you I really believe the roses
yeah and romance of music [ __ ] I know
what you mean like did I used to date a
stripper and like I used to believe her
she's like we can't [ __ ] here we can't
suck big well on camera and I was
telling all my friends yeah dawg she's
different for me and one day my cousin
is the manager he probably did it like
you before he knew he was like eight dog
come to the office real quick homie
nothing what's up he put that [ __ ] on
camera seven dog and I'm watching my
girlfriend sucks on the old man dick for
30 bucks and I'm like damn fool I never
I just walked out of her hey can I take
my lunch no I was just thinking of a way
to break up at there and I just I
remember just coming back like on a dog
you're gonna be sucking fulls dick make
sure you brush your teeth man you know
I'm gonna tell you about a deep deep
deep take this trip
lady Seminole when I put it out there
like I found out like on Monday that I
wasn't the [ __ ] take Bella's coat but
I knew the clock was ticking Bella was
waiting for a paycheck and how he was
putting the paycheck together was by
selling cars or taking some of this coke
that belonged to his room right and some
peanut right piece but like that so he
was asking around and giving out samples
he came to me directly with painting was
the only baby wasn't mine
- he looks but I'm sorry lot I'm sick
they go and listen I don't know a lot
about a lot of things 25 years old
let's face it I got nothing going on
let's be honest I got no future
you know I speak Spanish I don't have no
family I got no no I was clean joined it
yeah I'm good yeah [ __ ]
but in my mind we can let him have a
college education I told I was dead meat
and also this dude Jorge that reminds me
of a dude that I don't touch I don't I
just know I could sweat him I got you
I could make him take it out of the
house I knew I had this guy I knew I had
a show brother Bob oh how to tell will
him a little boy's room over there I
just yeah it was gonna go down that
luring think that's a weird gift to have
yeah I know what you mean and I didn't
know I had it until I read the same as a
bull Gravano book the secret about some
of the bull Gravano
but unless you read the book you do not
know is that yeah he claims he killed 19
it's more like 25 but 12 of those
murders you know what they weren't
judgment you coming over here to it yeah
you a trick you like that yeah you come
over you Tyler let's pretend
let's pretend I can't see what bar that
was you if the waiters were the unit
okay so I know that we could squeeze
dirty G's a week out of there I'll put
up the setup money everything we squeeze
out of that so I get my set of money is
mine after that we split 30 G's a week
15 jeez a week that's what that's
$60,000 that's a lolly that's clean
yeah so what he would do is I would I
know you George Oh 13 14 my right side
of the papers let's do this George we
signed the papers give you four months
you do it uh-huh then he'd let him take
over the business
and bring somebody else again that's
what he kept till if he kept killing
this partridge
oh my god how he would do it what we
wouldn't do to it I don't know let's go
for a drink
he walk you write it should all see like
what the [ __ ] yeah
fine once I read that I got really
scared about myself because it's an ugly
thing to have I could've lured anybody
in those days to blow I mean I said this
whole deal I was like a little man
bringing him to a dude but the more the
whole thing I'm trying to say is you
know what that dude that you know why
that dude wanted to kidnapped [ __ ]
that help me kidnapped that do mm-hmm
you know his motivation was okay
oh he spiel okay he was a fake bike he
was a fake everything he had two windows
he already had tattoo he would show out
every day yeah he was funny he was talk
to people again let me think about it
and talk to my partners
ah he was one of those dudes he always
had partners yeah that's I clipboard in
the end
this guy was a [ __ ] piece of work but
yeah it's good talk and I tried to get
walked a mile with that let me answer
question what if I knew a guy who had
two pieces and I could take him down you
interested you know real absolutely I've
done a couple of good boy all right
let's do it
let me get you all the details I'll
throw again we met somewhere low no
because what do you want to do it I'll
give me a couple days I'll be in touch
he would come to work the kid the kid
with the killers of machine-like it was
a savage he would sell cars and then go
and snore those like he hung out with
people who had money he had grown up in
bulk
his best friend had money and they were
strong like animals so you got to see
everything I got to get the gap from
yeah he was really good-looking and he
was living on the other he was making
like six thousand nine six thousand five
but his buddies were given him fifteen
thousand okay okay and nobody was saying
nothing plus he's setting up this kid
the kid's name is Randy who he was
setting up one day I got a knock on my
door that's his [ __ ] fake pie can do
she knows what I talked to you what are
we gonna do this I don't wanna do this
maybe Tuesday we'll make enough it - it
was like Sunday I'll never forget this
short you follow my house and bold I can
go listen we're going to you know I
really hear this money I know why what's
going on
I'm in love man oh really you have a
girlfriend leave us listen this is way
before the word it's complicated came up
this is 1987 nobody would say that one
it's complicated this guy was just
[ __ ] you know saying he was just a
[ __ ]
[ __ ] out he broke it down for me joining
us here's the deal there's this strip
collide Allen and this chick is [ __ ]
beautiful if she left out it because of
me
so she's sleeping in my bedroom and I go
are you what's going on I'm sleeping on
the couch you can see not having the
cipher no not yet I go so what do you
wait huh he goes well the money from
this [ __ ] kidnapping I'll take that
to pay for our divorce I know how much
is it before she's like 20,000 though
20g 2010 it was a lot of money i sat
there my jaw dropped
yeah so he was doing this to give her
money no you know what she did for a
living
yes what'd she do for a living stripper
not only a stripper but a complete nude
stripper BYOB oh [ __ ] sit on your lap
rub be a dick on her hand and jerk you
off between a [ __ ] come on a leg and is
a horror show
I do people what is there I worked a
costume and cost him said that's the
place where anything [ __ ] goes and I
do people like that people that girl's
name they got burnt one thing about that
girl she's super hot but she had this
Steven Kent believing that the reason
why she wouldn't have sex with him is
because she was married and he said he
was calm as she was Catholic she
couldn't sleep until she got the wood
but she can do coke and everything out
here the divorce is 20 G's she started
blow he was buying blow from there
because I would never forget when the
thing went awry bro you should have seen
it he was crying because he's like what
am I gonna tell her
what am I gonna tell using he had a
little guy with a rod this is different
guy he was a hotel right now
I think yet when he said the guy had
brought to this day we actually went to
the whole time I'm like I'm already in
[ __ ]
I'm already in trouble I'm gonna pull mm
he's in one [ __ ] day yeah you're
crazy I can't believe but this is what a
trip I'm on you dog I see you with such
a big heart and the way you are but like
you used to rob connects and how many
people understand like when you rob the
drug dealer like it it's going down I
remember like I didn't like to hang out
when I when I used to pick up dope in
1999 to 2003 whatever I hated being in
that drug house it's like being in the
waiting room I don't know dog you you
probably had more juice or you had that
one-on-one like I had to weigh in a
house where somebody brought it to you
then he he wanted to hit it like I
didn't buy this for you to hit it and
there was people there like I thought I
was going to get robbed and you know
what I mean it's like and in those
places what dude I left a connect once
where that [ __ ] place got robbed an
hour later and they [ __ ] those fools
up they beat the dogs up they didn't
[ __ ] around they came home with bats
beat up the dogs hit the bird cage at
the parakeet out they didn't get a spot
dog let me tell you something yeah we
like very different lines y'all remember
so much for you going to one of those
businesses yeah through everybody you
off guard
you gotta go in there locked loaded the
everywhere they go but the number one
thing you gotta go there this is what
the element of surprise see people on a
strip club waiting for two black guys to
come up with shotguns and say phrase
everybody hit the floor but let me tell
you something we just sit there with a
glass of water drinking close up and
also some guy comes in with a
especially it's upsetting people's
craniums and you hear people skulls
crack on this [ __ ] they start going down
one by one I think you just teeth they
go down five per minute God God God God
God God and you got five guys six guys
doing it with bats and two of them with
guns and I love that with an automatic
weapon two guys down the block with some
radios two more guys around the corner
with black cars come with scanners
that's how to take over those [ __ ]
allergist yeah that's SWAT tactical off
the street that's that's [ __ ]
you know dude you trained in the jungles
and [ __ ] to take over the crack houses
and you watch the schedule wants to
schedule you see when the package is
leave when they come back new though
that's some generals in the hitter bro
that's a complete different world that
was my world
I love that [ __ ] George I could snoop it
up I had a nose for it since 1981 Wow I
could find that [ __ ] and it's a comma
and I would see people and I would see
how they act and also I found out there
was drug dealer I would buy something
from them and head back off buying again
back off and by the third time George
they Scott's my own bank cards yeah you
catch him at 11:30 with three bumps on
them and they're like this is the best
sheet oh and again I got the cover I get
this from the guy called no moola you
know that he shows up every was a man I
bring a package that means if you come
in there guns blazing Thursday morning
at 7 o'clock it's ready it's ready for
you ain't gonna be ready no he didn't
cut it yet it's right now yes right
there he is he's been looking at it
slowly jerkily it has a great engine
with it every day so you take that door
and you throw a smoke bomb in there
what dude six and wanted a smoke bomb
please tell me in that something yes you
go wait here's my bomb anyway the
firework won this container you draw it
down it container hits the floor and
smoke comes out of it and it blows them
the [ __ ] out by the time they even
notice to smoke you got a gun done how
where's the cocaine I don't know you're
talking with their moms on the floor on
the table by the [ __ ] hair you put
your shotgun in her mouth
where's the cocaine into the closet take
the cocaine boom you have a cache in the
house no I don't I'll [ __ ] shoot her
in the leg [ __ ] yeah I got ten
grand the [ __ ] tank boom alright
boom nobody this never happened go back
to bed cap you got a car waiting down
the corner you get in you just call it
[ __ ] you know a kilo of coke which
you get for free you could drop it on
the [ __ ] straight that's
straight up 30k between four guys that's
not a bad holiday yeah you get one or
two of those a week you ballin have you
seen that movie Wonderland oh my it's
the movie about John Holmes
you know John Holmes hey I know it's
what we told ya where they [ __ ] robbed
the biggest Persian it is it takes place
in Hollywood and he convinces other guys
to go rob them for him and made him give
him no cup so he he gets caught and the
guy that catches the may comes go back
and kills everybody dog it's it's what's
that Street on me fountain when you're
[ __ ] on coke always take fountain it
takes place on fountain that's what's
crazy I remember you told me you have a
drug dealer by there would you did you
would do it right you got off because
you have to found you were going to be
on sunset you watch that movie wonder
that it's with Val Kilmer he plays John
Holmes and he after he's after he's done
doing pornos he becomes a big ass drug
addict and I guess like since he was
like the most famous porn star back then
all the millionaire's would invite him
to his parties and he would take people
back there to go rob you afterwards that
you said he would make you get
comfortable with them it's a [ __ ]
crazy moving I guess
the true story George from 84 to 87 so I
got caught other family people I clip
ran out fathers which in my world was it
time [ __ ] that wouldn't cut pure
there was times I hear that this guy's
has got going about next thing I see
this [ __ ] old scheme and I could
[ __ ] Jimmy and or thinking George it
was pathetic and then I got to the point
where when I was in it and Snowman
village what people knew I meant
business everybody hoping their doors to
me I want to honk bro your mouth goes
your mouth starts to go cuz you gotta
prove your point this cocaine I get from
this guy called El Guapo he drops it off
via helicopter you know and then we have
to go up there with Sneasel you know and
then they look at it and taste it and
test that 93 percent then you got to
start talking your [ __ ] although I get
this on the Jew to bring from Israel via
Colombia where they reprocess it it's 92
percent taste how clean this is and next
thing you know your mouth is going bro
what's the best [ __ ] you've got dawg
like from who was it in Cuba was in
Miami was in New Jersey where did you
get the best [ __ ] well you have to go
with the time periods in the time zone
and the evolution of cocaine and how it
went from being one thing to what is
today okay
when I was still snorting 2007 it was
very speedy cuz I got cut bad huh I
don't know you know now they put [ __ ] in
it right in Colombia Mexico
it was speedy it was also not cut with
the ether okay when I was going and when
I first started doing coke you do too
first
my own cochlea first year George I don't
every this play a trick on me yet strong
mucus back then I get this [ __ ] ever
realized I had a drink with oh I got you
now rank with it my song I got you I got
[ __ ] up his [ __ ] and it's the best
combo oh my god I'd do two lines and
have a pickle over - it might be [ __ ]
up my jaw would gonna be all happy and
talk to people and it was a party and I
love you and when my mum this check
comes in and have a million dollars
let's do another bump let's get another
crit I'm waiting for Ed McMahon
talking [ __ ] choice in those days I was
not thinking about entertainment I
thought that's a reason to walk in some
bicycle you're a funny guy let me put
you on it
I never doable of dishes or no audition
that's crazy
now now Joey like you know what's weird
dog is I knew you grew up did did you
ever do coke like like I heard cocaine
got [ __ ] up when it became crack like
did you do coke before they even made
crack or what yeah let me tell you what
happened yeah
this was the bottom line about what
happened I was I was exposed to cocaine
a young age did I look at it and stuff
not really I'm not a lot of detail like
that the first time I looked at cocaine
was October of 79 hellos - that was the
first time and I'll elaborate on that
some other time
but I took a little bit of it like maybe
two and a half grams Wow I took it up to
my room at that time I had a promise at
that time I had snorted THC crystal and
you know what killed me a muscle on THC
first book that I violated my number-one
rule I wouldn't ever put none of the
Empire those okay that was that's not an
assault at all private personal rule so
I did not want to put some on my nose so
what's a goodness he'd see I said okay
I'll stop with that
I got a lung infection it took me to the
hospital
scrape my monthly publisher and they
scrape my wallet I thought it was the TT
crystal was gonna be in the results I
was [ __ ] 15 years old
ah three days I sweated and asked a
little bit thinking I was gonna come up
positive for THC crystal would explain
my [ __ ] lungs oh my god and in his
head none I never said I'm gonna cop so
he'll be done Hollywood London to hip
why detective test I don't know nothing
I don't know nothing so no joints but
then I looked at her for a couple days I
held in my drawer hidden and one day I
was gonna play hooky my sowwy
and I took it with me I'm gonna sell it
today yeah she landed up with the dude I
do is cool as [ __ ] and I knew if we did
it he would never say that I never said
it so we all cut out of school went back
to his house our friend came over but
they were in the basement me and him
upstairs like some peppermint schnapps
and vodka what cries we took a bunch of
crushed ice and crushed it into little
pebbles Lisa and then we filmed the
glasses up with just that and then we
sprinkled cocaine on top if we drank
like two of those let me go really in
big shared with us this is way before
Scarface guys this is 1979 and my man
lube his kitchen
all right at 11:30 and the boy like a
week before Halloween or in his kitchen
there's maybe six dudes downstairs with
a case of quarts what the court court
32 ones be is a big all I got you here's
the problem we just robbed a beer truck
we were going to eat breakfast and we
saw a beer truck delivery and we pulled
over a little come on let's take a beer
we took him for a case but it was courts
so whatever we do we had a couple
options we can bring it to like a store
and trade it out and pay a few bucks
and the game makes links for five bucks
with a sober thing or we take him back
to your house we fill your tub up would
be a slice that's existed okay we took
it back to the kids house but scoops the
[ __ ] ice on it from the store waited
10 minutes we bought another [ __ ]
five hated beer everybody downstairs was
smoking pot outside and drinking nobody
knew me and my dog were upstairs about
to do a blast and we just kept looking
at each other what you think so we do it
let's try it with char let's try this
thing let's do it
we had already drank two drinks with the
cocaine sprinkled on yeah then I had
your blood getting your brain with thing
all my hair was growing and once we did
those first two words I wasn't hooked it
wasn't I heard Black Sabbath snowblind
the little made sense to me at all going
into a deep dark area now I knew this
[ __ ] ah but that was it that was
basically the first that it took me like
maybe two weeks to do it again maybe
three weeks yeah when you're young it's
hard to find like as an adult I wanna
pick listen I always tell people this is
how old I am you saw what happened with
California what weed how one day you go
somewhere to buy weed down you could
pull over as long as you have your
license and your ID and you can pull
over go something loving oh [ __ ] there's
a weak start right there hold on give me
five minutes hon you know one day you
sign the paperwork they ask you two
stupid questions
they buzz you to give you an envelope
with papers wider [ __ ] roach clip and
you get a free edible that's hard [ __ ]
and they give you a gram of certain
weight yeah that [ __ ] yeah so strong
were yet this [ __ ] like their cousin
snuck into the tire
my boys well you saw what happened here
in California you thought I saw the
growth of cocaine just how we saw the
weed growth oh I got rid from we were
doing acid drinking and smoking pot -
[ __ ] the acid which was $3 a hit tops
combined $50 half a gram and we would
split that between two people that was a
lot Ben you're in high school
[ __ ] yeah opanka I didn't even touch it
I was an adult about open air opening
bang out when you're in high school
Judi 25 bucks to open up at the club
because we were getting a half gram no
matter what either you're is oh yeah if
you're raising you talk your friend into
it maybe get a poem or leave it
that's goodnight ball throw some cut on
it because the [ __ ] would get in his
[ __ ] fire anyway yeah well who was
like the biggest rock group at that time
like what music were you [ __ ] bump
with a David Bowie like what were you
bumping to enjoy that high of coke let's
face it there's really no music that you
enjoy at that beginning level of cocaine
yeah you're right cuz I'll enjoy man
later but I do remember one memory that
still to this day one when I was a kid
at one point there were two dudes in the
neighborhood and I was friends with both
I love them both dearly there was a
problem no choice these two dudes had
fought oh I think heaven in a haze on
each other so every time I would talk to
one guy on the way out he'll tell your
buddy I got mine I'm still gonna [ __ ]
him up and every time I hang out with
Lee Lee would say to me dawg
now your buddy I got mine like catchable
he is nice all he did to me this one on
three-year and Friends of Bolton guess
what happens my mother does oh the one
dude says to me you won't live with me I
said absolutely and move in everything's
[ __ ] tremendous one night who do I go
out with Dede and he has a heart attack
and I hang out with deeds I love you
yeah that time do you was a [ __ ]
pisser
he was tough we [ __ ] [ __ ] well he was
two years younger than me
if I was 16 Dede was 14 Wow no I'm
drinking with men and saying like a
[ __ ] Savage that's why they called
the man chop I was really a [ __ ]
animal of death of sake so we both
became they both became heated so one
night I'm working on a gas station and I
roll this attendant freaky Freddy dude
I'm supposed to rob him by an able and
chop up the 8 ball with him under forget
like we had done this 10 times I kicked
them in the stomach like when I do you
think I'm exactly this guy got robbed if
they look back at the New Jersey logs of
gas stations that got robbed diamonds
the evil with the cops
dr. Caulder that gas station will get
robbed three tons of fun judge hear what
the cops like a 500 feet away they would
be drinking coffee 50 feet away they
would still rob that cat season because
if you read The One Direction you ran
into like joint Keller's house and this
other girl's house it was kind of [ __ ]
up in those days but there's a bridge
there
you can make it to the bridge you're
pretty good there's still a little at
that time it was underdeveloped and [ __ ]
okay at that point you have two roads
going opposite directions
there's exits that those days I remember
looking at that what the [ __ ] we talk
about the Great Lord I got robbed by the
there's a liquor store they used to get
robbed by the police station and all
over the gas station so this one day
this dude's have [ __ ] jack though
he's telling me you got to rob me every
once in a while because that's given my
way from sleeping me I must have [ __ ]
him up a couple times for Saturday fuzzy
this dude would ask me how much money I
have only 400 me go yeah you're right I
always he always had 700 800 so we split
the money by an Eightball wow that was
the deal
in those days I got an 8-ball for 250 so
if I'd robbed by say 400 we each take so
many finals we got a ball off the top
Danny [ __ ] he's smarter to get away
you're right so he took a beatin yeah he
took two punches to the face [ __ ] up
his eyebrow it was a big and I bring
Dini with me I lucked out and we robbed
it but this time I'm living with this
other character who I love dearly still
today and he would give me [ __ ] about
hanging out with me - one night I got
this whole night planned I'm gonna hook
up or freaky Freddy I'm gonna rob him
once and for all he's never gonna save
me what's he know the cops he's freaky
Freddy he's already taken thirty front
punches for me what feeling bit but he
knows I can [ __ ] not from the [ __ ]
out at this age at this point it wasn't
easy two o'clock of a head I'd done it
thirty times already so I take the coke
and my plan is to take the coat I got a
case of being lined up and then go back
to where I'm living because the dude I'm
living was supposed to go out and be in
DVF
how about left and then xi Li Jana
Nene's house and snort there to his
brother get home at three or four from
the corner yeah you get a separate spot
so we had the tremendous thing won't
guess what way before we get overhead I
call over there my boy called it was on
my goal Allah these guys hate each other
yeah I walked in first night Iron Man
here's the deal we brought beer there's
weeds here your parents had come home
tomorrow
can you make pieces just came tonight
he's here because all right a little bit
and this guy played like a big-shot was
16 years old
this guy's like thank you welcome to my
house let's forgive by gonna [ __ ] I
would you dick Jones I just do good
drink so we got this code burning at
home my pockets I don't like how we're
gonna get rid of homeboy I filled New
Coke in oh boy yeah well did he ever the
homeboy actually you know homeboy drinks
a full beer and he goes hold on I hope
to the bedroom Tigger that he lays down
believe if you take it and is a hardy
passed out of yoga that you guess what
how I just come up
Rapper's Delight oh yeah even those that
we put down baby George I'm alright we
put that out one maybe eighty two prints
that night no no no no we just kept
snorting that's [ __ ] a ball being
this case snoring that ain't ball funny
when he kinda came through about five
the white was coming out we took off we
went to a park with like eight beers
yeah and we said once the Sun come up
and we stored the rest and that's the
first time I go home I got [ __ ] up my
jaw was going oh I was paranoid now that
that planning you're paranoid at that
point it was still fun I was still
social yeah I could go to your house and
you wouldn't know I was tweaking you
know saying I was still at that point of
cocaine
yeah like you get to a point where you
catch all your actions and your stick on
[ __ ] I'm acting like the yeah
I can't believe I'm doing that so the
next day I'm gonna forget I saw freaky
Freddie you think what happened to the
Kofi and I gotta believe it accounts for
me over [ __ ] you up the cops didn't know
nothing I had took me to the hospital
where's my end my wife is on my ass she
had been jacket on that night with a
bikini
his wife weigh like 400 pounds and what
they would do is they really they were
getting the coke they would go to
Jacuzzi delivered in those days the
company would come to a set up a Jacuzzi
in your living room
oh and you walk him into it and you
could have sex in their mission and they
came back a nice day
they put the frame day table they let
you [ __ ] hang but not out
oh my god hysterical so she was huge she
never even left the apartment
it was one of those situations in a way
he could have sex with it
as if he would give her bull cocaine
it was crazy George and I'm [ __ ] 16
years old yeah dog that's crazy I never
saw freaky Freddie again and this is New
York Jersey right this is Jersey via
1980 baby I had worked at the gas
station I lasted I'm not because that he
told me I gotta take a 50 on the way out
he got me here from you got me here from
6:00 till 2:00 in the morning I'm
dissing parties yeah that eight bucks an
hour ain't covered in terms of $50 make
just to work just to walk in that's that
that was the term in those days that was
life there were some people took you to
for 200 right off the top
I know a bartender in New York that the
first day I start at this place he goes
listen we take one for you off the top
[ __ ] so you missed but in those days
yeah but you each had a register in
those days again eight guys $6 of beer
that's 48 bucks
you would ring in eight bucks okay you
understand you understand though you
[ __ ] put it in there was no cameras
it was really and guess what you can see
on those days take that money to start
all over again
I never G out me and that's when you
clear the register right off the top I
am Joey so it's cool there was no
computer it was a roll paper uh-huh all
you do is get that paper cut it out yeah
put the [ __ ] bait of it all even a
muffin give you know what I don't know
nothing y'all plug the register plug the
back in him [ __ ] you think you're
dealing drugs story I'm George Perez I
gotta run to the bathroom a little bit
don't even care wrap it up so yeah Lee
you know what Lee and you always ask me
crazy questions go ahead ask me any
wonder okay so I've been watching a lot
of lockup there's a bunch of lock ups on
all so glad on Netflix I'm obsessed with
them what did you obsess with okay
it seems like everyone is just like a
whole liar straight to your face ever L
at all times from the guards to the
other inmates and like it's just simply
a crazy place to be like a lie to are
you watching like lockup in California
and Mississippi Alabama watch all of
them wonder what I'm watching now I was
like first-timers okay I got you well
let me to break your let me break you
down all those people that are
interviewing I'll lock up those are all
special need yard offenders what does
that mean
they're tattletales rapists pedophiles
snitches or or they're like men that
have tits or they're like yeah it's they
put them on a special need yard so you
know like so you don't like the people
unlock a [ __ ] no I hate those
[ __ ] but you know once in a
while they'll the blacks they don't go
they go to a different kind of politics
because on the real prison yard they're
not allowed to come and interview you
and then they go crazy with the cameras
no like we won't let it happen it just
won't happen like yeah they must they
must control it I know there's many
people out there with the camera yeah
because the
they're on like a again have you seen
that new one they got this one where
they send they put you in the county
jail and luck that nope my watch and I'm
not gonna be on that you know like like
they may put a regular person in there
to try to convince the convicts to think
they're convicts
we've been watching that and it's [ __ ]
crazy because they one chick found out
that this other chick was a cop too and
she was like hey you're here for an year
for the program
I like she was like checking on like
[ __ ] you need to act better because I
can tell you you've never been locked up
and they don't know how to adjust to it
I wouldn't know how to adjust do it
that's it's a like that I never want to
go I don't know I thought would not
survive you'd love Italy no one you
would start your own podcast in there I
would try like five Walkmans and some
Hanako nationally knowing their show
what you to do with the computer and you
know how to make things happen and next
thing you know yes always protected
raise madam I think nobody you have to
just become what it was that worried
that Rambo was uses they used to always
use your gesture I'm just I forgot
nobody [ __ ] knows you take care of
nothing
Allison Rambo in a while man expendable
expendable once you become [ __ ] me
them damn could make everybody there
prosper and happy yes and you make the
main guy happy that's it as long as
you're doing graphics for the main dude
[ __ ] that he likes that he sends out
yeah what I'm no you know I said you're
coming now people gotta pay you give him
a Vig everybody's happy
why not Lee yeah Alicia not getting
[ __ ] in the ass by a Mac you'll scare
him or basically Aryan Nation what if
Jewish gangs no no you are going you
have one Milan here's a deal they would
have to read use but they don't know
what they do is they walking around
would be
he is looking around a refocus eyes I
can't hide it
although what you do is you go with it
and you go right to the [ __ ] Mexicans
as you know let me make sure that you
get alliances these Mexicans are the
brothers you would do better with the
brothers can you teach them [ __ ] you
know computers how to do a podcast want
to know that I think they're not maybe
the baddest black dude wants to be a
rapper
he just needs a mixtape his [ __ ] yeah to
bust his [ __ ] game you go right
to the head of the black dudes listen my
name is Lisa at my podcast producer I'm
gonna produce from ton can but the
[ __ ] he talkin about man
man listen excuse me sorry miss I love
it I'll give you that much time to
explain you're not a very very very
effective you'll be fine
I just got some ongoing every religion
doesn't overpower race ain't even like
look it's all about the Benjamins the
end of the [ __ ] day
all right I tell them how they gonna
make money all these yeah you're gonna
be like everything you make they get a
piece a lot of respect you understand
you at the [ __ ] respecting level it
doesn't matter because I'm not gonna
respect your [ __ ] would you rather
respect go to the hospital when you're
27 with enemies or giving $10 out of the
40 you're making which ain't gonna make
you break it you understand me give some
[ __ ] you give somebody $10 and bag of
cookies in prison ain't nothing
happening to your ass only side ten
dollars in a bag of cookies
well what did someone else want $10 in
the bag of cookies they gotta you give
it to 10,000 bag of cookies he smooths
out lumps in the bumps okay he says
Joyce listen until police are yet yeah
he's my good money I'm saying nothing
could happen to him he's very good with
the computer in fact his sister needs a
passport
so type enough for you in 30 days 300
ahead give me 50 off the top tell your
mom to poke 50 on my books straight up
right straight up that's it and you'd
the money for him
he works for you now give him two points
and he's a good man to be around Jorge
Perez and that's how you do it Lee and
next thing you know on Sundays George
Korres brings in Mexican food the black
dude brings in cheeto by Popeyes Chicken
you have no family and actually no they
invite you in and you read with them on
Sunday
it's a weirdest [ __ ] thing you banana
yeah dude Lee I know you'd make it
because visitation day yeah people bring
in food yeah I know you'd make it
because the last prison I was at I used
to work at this guy that was a 54 year
old little white man that was in the for
attempted murder because they try to
jump him at a bar and embarrass them and
this guy was fragile cool but like since
he knew me now and we work together
he worked x-rays and I work on the yard
so if I needed cigarettes or anything
took to the x-ray department he was like
I haven't had a singer and four years
dog now I smoked one every day because
of you and exactly what you said man you
put bread to the basket dog they'll be
nice you protect your butt holy is that
like your fear getting butt raped in
prison uh that's not breaking be ups not
great it's also hold on the whole this
is the whole idea of prison so this day
George Perez killer came out of prison
got a gonna go rob the bank yeah [ __ ]
that
you know prison is intended to give you
fear its what fear you when I was 22 dog
I know fan hell man I always thought I
was gonna go away you know I know people
yeah and go to judge ice when I can joke
I was delusion because when I was found
those people made calls attorneys showed
up they knew the deal here only I'm
walking with three I'm [ __ ] dirty
sense away from a corner and I'm [ __ ]
walk around thinking yeah I could do
whatever the [ __ ] I want and if I get
nailed especially nothing
I can make a few calls week at that time
I could it would be my first arrest I
really say a good kid this never
happened with him before bla bla bla
laughing I'm sick yeah you know but
eventually you get nailed
eventually you get [ __ ] down if you
committed some of these other because
felonies are things that you don't even
realize you're doing at the time yeah I
have a felony man that's no [ __ ] joke
well I did that with with that dude with
even with the gun I always talked the
back of my mind I'd get away with it
until while I was doing it and so like
you felt like the steel in your hand and
the trigger you're like damn dawg
this is good really yeah like they could
just shoot you for having that this
isn't this point here at that time I
didn't get anxiety when I got was his
heat in my head and I would hear voices
and [ __ ] now with you I'm hearing noises
right now as I said this is getting far
would you like a star district here
alright just in case you want to use
yeah you like Mexican me right now good
good good good you supposed to look
myself on living each other
yes Michonne I was here tonight sans
fresh with [ __ ] people my girl
Jessica jewel my man mark on a bartender
at the Chop House in Milwaukee [ __ ]
tremendous place if you ever Milwaukee
go to the Chop House and see my man
Marco he brought me a beautiful I'm
George Carlin live live in the Carnegie
Hall I also want to give a shout out to
my girl Charlie who drove down and hung
out with us and Ellie Stewart Richards
RG Madden who took the food
recommendations Thank You Lee doesn't
even take my food recommendations my
brother I give you some little RG madam
I don't have a lot welcome here no you
haven't
Polly thing turn you want to llamas me
be denote oh you know I love you they
can big down
Dayton marry Matthew McDowell I'm sorry
Matthew McDowell Nathan Merrick and
Robert Lord bells unlike that you know I
love you [ __ ] and the afternoons
I'm stone when I'm writing these and
that's just the way it works now I'm
getting a [ __ ] I'm at stage 2 called
working out with Joey next Thursday
night I think it's 10 bucks
I'm going there with a notebook at night
out at the ice house I'm gonna notebook
I just talk for a [ __ ] hour leaves to
be there taping he's always the
assistant assistant oh my god listen
there's a fish now oh my god I'll be
selling 26 at the shoulder God my ball
be sold 26 and that's the way you have
any dates Doug that we could come see ah
no not right now not this week I'm
taking the week off as far as good good
give us hot casa yeah Georgie has a
bangin new podcast or so it was like
number 17 or the 17th one I don't know I
think I owe 17 months no you gotta come
up here lemon will beat you halfway and
I'll do it off I'll come to you god I
would love it yeah it's called George
Perez stories it's on iTunes so I'm kind
of Google put I'm new to a dog like I'm
loving it you're the one that like I
remember after I did Rogan you brought
me and you check me and I was a dog
thank you for that push man like yes a
duel but guys you have a voice oh thank
you but like it's weird like I I didn't
know how much work you have to put into
a dog and I gotta give you props are you
and Lee [ __ ] this is some work ugh some
work give everything you have to stay on
top of this I love it
knocking oh hell I love it then I have a
good partner you know he's always on
time he's punctual he does his job
there's no drama he makes me laugh my
ass off for the last 20 minutes he's
keep looking okay yeah
messages listened for years felishj used
to come to me and say we have to cut
down on the episodes and make the best
of I never people with everything on our
deal I get hit up a pantheon and all
that stuff
I would never relay on ideal I would
never ever ever come to you instead I'm
than one I'm gonna give you this for a
dollar but I tell you what I will do for
a dollar I will get somebody to cut 35
minutes of Lisa heads head bouncing back
and forth any kind noses okay and for an
extra bonus under what we'll give you
but he's going to do for dollar you
donate to your favorite charity really
wasn't dollar let's do that I put to
make me feel good I don't want to do six
months and just camera work one camera
week taping two hours a night of all his
head move is beginning to ending we'll
give you three episodes and you could
vote for the best one okay we're going
to give you options here this is very
smart I get why they dollars for one
another three episode what click it that
I want to add the dollars for one
another three Kate donate to under this
we don't care there's no dollars then
you're gonna die this is to prove I'm
telling you why I'm telling you that you
people watching shitty comedy comedy is
sitting over here trying to talk to
again well I'm [ __ ] watching we say
that back the life look at the [ __ ]
feeling
Bacon's awake he looks like a fish
that's waiting for his own look at the
computer scratch his head rub his
eyeballs
it's a nut making little noises well you
only what you would take less stars than
I do now I know you can oh I Firestone
one of this unit
yeah yeah a slushie huh
oh my god I'm getting some stuff sent to
me that you just porn to drink and 250
milligrams you can make like a shake out
of it
no well I'm most importantly look like a
gator hear something okay
like a protein drink no I might have
protein I remember Alma tang
George Perez it's good to see you good
to see me man you're gonna make me feel
warm
I'm not wrapping up getting [ __ ]
you're rocking and rolling George
flowers radio and fun promoting [ __ ]
stone to the gills and the story that
I'm [ __ ] high as [ __ ] can I enter on
a shower a dust and who gave me a note
giving up Joe inches and I'm too fat for
your shirts and gave me some somebody so
thank you thank you
Milwaukee the people came to the pack
stated I also want to thank the people
that came to a magic hat toppers the
more I think about it it was a different
type show for me and I gotta tell you
something I felt great about the shows
but most important I'm happy you people
[ __ ] came huh I started no room you
people wanted more tickets you responded
with one in the big room you know what
we didn't sell out but it was a great
[ __ ] audience oh thank you for coming
out Friday night and Michigan the
Canadians who drove down thank you for
coming now [ __ ] Saturday night you bad
[ __ ] just like that George
Perez you know I'm sorry as well sob
back as I know I'm home for five [ __ ]
weeks trying to dig up new [ __ ]
material yeah I called you in your
Milwaukee I was like what are you doing
like I'm a [ __ ] Starbucks in
Milwaukee leaned over they leak a little
bit I know you're likely order I wasn't
there but my accident I just remember
you saying that [ __ ] no that was when I
called you I don't want to target where
I called Jocasta you won't believe what
happened last night oh yeah yeah I was
here was I hear how your my waffling I
was Thursday I called you Thursday no it
was Friday
you're my walkie Friday weren't you yeah
because I called you in the daytime it
was like two o'clock
I coffee yeah it wasn't really it was a
friend of mine okay my bad my bad he's
looking on your league I know we suppose
we will show you have you said he's gone
ziplining yelling yeah how does your
fine master you know you want a group on
there looks like they made them pay
Raimi couldn't get out I remember they
gave a physical they all look like jelly
no they put him on that road was all
let's all [ __ ] I'm gonna play and
under breakfast in the morning
politically a 98 year old man got
carried on the mountain and you could do
it I don't know why we couldn't do
there's a caveman keep him in his coffee
huh and he could do it and like export
of the group got taken out silently she
broke the rope to not break anyone if
she did better tape them but I am now
and I'm still able Holly you can't do it
oh my god broken rope like a Buddha a
monk ultimately if I took a rope right
they're not using a home depot like what
color was the discussion role like what
kind of pressure they have a very
specific the planning rope that doesn't
smell so good but what's there between
you hold on to a right for one minute
can be zip line but the [ __ ] was that
there was a Friday I don't know what
you're talking about like no will just
make you jump and pick you up right
you'll grab a rope and just hold it for
a minute okay yes I know you can another
good that's about to hold it there's
about to be a [ __ ] harness and a bar
you will
I had you to the camp and I put you hook
over the bag to do they pay you and [ __ ]
you knock your legs on a lake in two
different movies Batman and Batman is
brother Bernard is the second time -
doesn't you give me your favorite guy of
course ah when I was gonna tell most
everything I was written great I wasn't
not great the best shape of my life
whatever but I could sit in a heartless
they don't have promises for like ever
hammering Fitch model Joey you could fit
a harness no I am probably harnesses oh
they don't
yes thank you wait how you break the
harness did you break the harnesses no
could you break like the latch belt
what broke actually cured only one look
at you I nothing broke what happened I
think you're interested in passing no
goddamn it
they didn't like my break and my hand
was been good I'm smooth enough that's
why everyone I can't hit let you do that
the bridge test right now you know how
you break him to [ __ ] off you don't know
how to use the bridge you broke the rope
was a break
show miss never is terrible and let me
be everybody lovely oh my god like I
wanna kill and they're mean to the head
of dog in the office to make this tea
nice ok no way every time cuz I can we
going again but it's over a quarter of
the group gets checked off so they go
back to the office in the managers like
no we're not giving your money back
although we'll give you at we'll give
you a coupon but it's like an hour
outside of the middle nowhere see you
have to go and then and they believe
like ten minutes later all the wasted
time and money but then yeah they got
you does oh my god you have to scam
that's a good boy that's crazy damn
people who want scams are crazy the
other piece is [ __ ] how you do that
oh you track him to the [ __ ] I'm glad
I'm [ __ ] high as fire broke the rope
German I did not get damaged Joey these
are some [ __ ] up we don't laugh and it
was a special roast snake hisses yeah
the [ __ ] rope
they [ __ ] grease it with something no
no good reason why they do this well
then how do you glide on if they holy no
good any of the plan is really open
you're gonna roll past winters this [ __ ]
they coat that with some certain and I'm
a classy girl it's like a plastic right
then they finish it with a plastic then
they put a loop on that and they put a
harness on that with a level ring and
you sit in the harness like a child and
strike now with your legs okay they had
a hard time with the harness Utah is a
hardness it fit anybody and while you're
under 250 little it high so you got in
the harness I got in the heart of
momentum okay were there any panic sighs
what whether it offended you give the
rope by gold I haven't heard one panic
sign but I was fine I've done it before
I don't know it it was a we just if it's
a man that drives up the mountain is
cool cuz hydraulics in it and you get
out there's like one little prat get one
try and they're like nope and then
baby's over no see it looks like nothing
that's not good and like a while long
did you go five minutes nothing like and
then I go over there and then never take
you home I'm like what and I'll get you
can't you're not good enough on the rule
wait can we try again no there's no time
Wow there's not any expensive so [ __ ]
them I'm glad to ever business you
then they heard the rope wrap initially
I read the overboard I can't do wanton
yeah I read that contour attack oh yeah
well I attack them on Yelp and sponson
they said that they weighed you the
scales awesome they took a chance the
hardest shaky
Marmont disintegrate when I took it off
Oh like that Oh [ __ ] sure which is
why I love you to death I guess what
we're going on a gorge in your life a
lot of parenting right now are my kids
21 18 and yet are they going through the
changes in life like I want to do this I
want to truck I want that I want a car
so I got a you know I got to give a
little help out a little starter kit for
them they work in it's cool my I've been
spend a lot of time of my daughter
podcasting a lot lately and a lot of
less partying dog you know I've been
doing a lot more of the hustle I like it
you know chillin with red band all the
time that's my boy right there that's
that segment yeah the party it takes up
so much of your time
Sakia it's 20 25 30 hours a week if you
party five minutes a week to find party
Joey tonight you go out and you get
[ __ ] up hon we like you need a Mexican
hot dog and you go home and pass the
[ __ ] out hell yeah all loaded with
onions with [ __ ] how about a lot
Heidi roses [ __ ] you go right home and
basa and there's the other things where
the mystery night well you havin a good
time at the mud and there's no three
chicks eight guys let's go this guy's
house yeah partying Nico's comedies kind
of house for sale that's definitely yeah
that's what [ __ ] me up is I was always
partying with the strippers after work
and you know they just got done hustling
drug dealers sold
is they just like me because they
thought you know what if we [ __ ] him we
don't got a tip them a lot no more that
was their hustle too so I was just like
you know what [ __ ] it they got good
drugs i party with them and I was I
couldn't recover I would still be going
on I would be I worked the next day then
I go do Kali
like I never let my body recover until
like two days later everything all [ __ ]
I could probably sleep for eight hours
there was some crazy Shelby's this time
I was like 37 36
I went strong so I hit about 40 huh I
did that 40 be kind of be acting with
the gun oh you're absolutely right 37 38
I mean what was a sleep apnea went from
level 6 to level 1 fine I didn't know
what it was I thought it was the cocaine
that wasn't let me sleep in it that
would take a double killing [ __ ] and
that would knock me out for a little
while I was scary thought I can imagine
now man what started [ __ ] me up is
like I started seeing myself in the
mirror and I hated it I was petrified of
myself I was just like look at your
[ __ ] face you catch yourself when
you're period
oh yeah yeah a doctor if I can stick on
you lift up your toes see wicked
gentlemen take your dick out you kind of
feel good about yourself your pinion
it's yellow there's no blood it's like
you know marci yellow and almost when
you look up at them you look up you just
look up and there's the mirror and there
you are
it's 548 the boys ah you should've
believed five [ __ ] hours ago if
you're going to me you have to get up in
the morning with your kids
it's 548 your eyeballs over
you and I both know at this point in our
lives when I hit the sack 298 you still
got five ten bumps to do and that's all
my god yes because you don't want to
take a second or you know obviously do
the rest of me I thought by that point
you're that high anymore but you said
yourself you know what I'll come on snow
a little and you jerk off I pass yeah
and your jerk-off six cards nothing
comes up and I won't point you wake up
six and a half hours later thirsty as a
[ __ ] good and when you wake up
you're not to just we used together yeah
it's just two little words like you know
things are calm and there's like other
matters
you have no fluid left in your body get
dehydrated super D I get up you open up
that refrigerator it's iced tea with no
lemon you inhale that [ __ ] you just have
just need fluids orange juice war
anything oh my god it's [ __ ] town
like this any of that and you know what
to like ah my back fine he feels better
like I was doing so much coke back then
like I think they were cutting it was
almost [ __ ] my back up I was too
young to have a [ __ ] y'all back that I
stopped doing it and drink a lot of wine
on my back is back your back my back is
bashing back like a [ __ ] lease is
what's your deal when I come to your
take on this also joined the final time
what's your final four right - so my
final thought is drugs are crazy I just
uh
I have a lot of stuff that I have a
[ __ ] up with me on but I'm glad
they're chasing me I may seem grateful
that I never have to happen me
cuz it's just how it sounds like it's
grape or just terrible
yeah the same time what are you gonna do
instead
thank God get on down to it yeah thank
god you're not 28 and a halfway house
you've managed to Nelly say you know
what I got taste on we had a good time
at the halfway house I wanted to watch
yeah but I went a was miserable and
stuff they beat me it was an education
that system the time and this is
straight up those you can be Nation guys
education had a lesson I learned a lot
it just slowed me down a lot I was good
you know that was a lucky break that is
Gundam go that was lucky break that
[ __ ] and shine I had a thousand lucky
breaks I got a good attorney we found a
few loopholes lose the 1440 bill for the
first time you got arrested and it was
nonviolent you got your time cut in half
so I'd already been two months in county
which is four months I gave some time
sir yes I gave me when you gave me 18
[ __ ] months that means I'm really
don't I'm I only really got [ __ ] the
14 which rather right here eligible for
halfway out mr. hodda go this try to put
me through DLC even though I was
eligible for a halfway house rode me
through the system for me to diagnostic
the whole [ __ ] Quebec [ __ ] I thought
they would just send me right to a
halfway house with a sense man and why
we do this biscuit [ __ ] no they took me
into the murky waters of your daughter
trying to drown your doggy [ __ ] that
[ __ ] I kidding Goodall half a house yeah
no I'm just a weirdo like that I like
when I was in prison I like being by
myself
oh no halfway house imagine having like
20 roommates and a [ __ ] living room I
don't know I don't know I've always
wondered this okay let's go let's say I
have a romance
I'm snore what's gonna happen manic tell
me you're gonna get punched to stop
snoring I know
now I mean amen you work it out that's
when you you give them your a own you
know what honey i know i bug you in
light here's orange and apple i get from
lunch gotta pay it off and when i walked
in i shared a seven-man room two
bedrooms a couch two bedroom and two
couches it was two per bedroom
so with two two something weird in one
living room there was a bed somewhere
else a lot of those crazy and you have
to move your way up
okay that's the first level is those two
apartments and George Perez you move
quick it's 75 hours a week you gotta pay
them for groceries yeah you gotta pay to
live and a half I help you have to pay
them 150 in those days per week deliver
the halfway house did they supply you
food or gonna get you up every five a
week for food on top of the roof okay
and then bring you one of their on some
one day you picked up two grocery bags
it was a headless processed American
cheese meat patties frozen a once in
state that was branded on sale like we
don't buy it today he's gonna run away
and shake yeah a package of pork chops
pour the can George it was the weirdest
thing
ice-t De La Soul rocking crazy and you
picked her out and walked out there he
had to eat yeah I can do that [ __ ] I
don't know it it would just [ __ ] me up I
don't know I mean I of course I do it if
I had to but I would prefer I'd rather
this be in prison I was into a
seven-bedroom but within three days
George or the house Mouse I already had
them to cook so yeah Byron he was so
drunk and one time I was waiting she
walked it what she thought it was my
thing for the ceilings and uh she's like
Jesus this feeling is terrible like
epsilonc and Coke in there
they put me into a 3-bedroom so I
started off on the couch of it but to do
that was with he was a ruby request for
it so he's got a hefty offer honking him
up but there was a dude and it was cool
as [ __ ] but he was long the tight side
he looked just like Ed not we call him
going and ginger pissed off I don't done
doesn't yeah man the I slit when I was
in prison I was in a dorm want it was a
hundred man dorm and I that was some
you're walking on eggshells at night my
friend I love drew beds woman it was a
it was an it was like an old Navy
barracks and they had 50 bucks and 100
[ __ ] and it had like 12 showers
12 restroom heads because it was what
the Navy used to use to train back into
some old Navy barracks and I hated that
[ __ ] dude that was the worst [ __ ] ever
because you could hear snoring at night
you can't you can't do anything but a
hundred person room No thank you you
could smell feet hell that [ __ ] oh you
just know farts no my chisel your mouth
open
I'm gonna fart a fart stuck to your
tooth like the inside of your mole you
move your tongue like this vanilla
Knightley that's [ __ ] up you bro you
they do burped why I'm sitting there
with my full child at the airport in
Detroit this [ __ ] great place to see
and we stopped at this one [ __ ] we saw
I forget them we carefully found mr.
come on let's take a walk up there's no
real
five so he walked up with his [ __ ]
half a man pointy we watch we do our own
thing yeah
what the [ __ ] is gonna tie guilt I
forget what I've been saying I'm [ __ ]
storm highs this stars kicking in now
this she was kicking to it I see purple
everywhere view I'm watching for over
four weeks and this this is like the
party you're going to eat when that okay
there's someone here eat with that
there's purple right there all right
whatever am i me too I threat this
[ __ ] and I'm hot as [ __ ] the way
I'm supposed to be jumping alive you
know about the honey coffee son right
now
yeah was my eyes and goes nappy doing
you think I'm [ __ ] with you
you think I'll [ __ ] with that's a high
and - I juggle had something to please
me - let me meet a hole under one I had
a whole dog yeah then I had the cab the
[ __ ] time out in the camera laughing
yeah I have about six or seven rather
than a formal and funny I fall man what
is funny I three right and funny boat
now I eat those gorillas who opened up
the bag who ripped it open at least ours
Angie I don't know you just deploy them
everything we have 695 stuff I at least
six oh yeah I just had one I ain't
[ __ ] I use my phone yeah I think and
I told you the yeah you guys think yeah
the only thing two minutes ago I drink
water eat [ __ ] and stretch a little bit
these things are good for you scars are
good psychologically abuse they [ __ ]
with you little bit if you get lost you
go find
way around the [ __ ] room a map is a
well George oh thank you but I'm just
trying you know I'm happy in the game
you're still putting it together your
[ __ ] yeah thank you brother for all the
advice I got no questions you know the
[ __ ] deal work hard and you're really
a [ __ ] rot yeah and when they call
you're prepared and nobody can [ __ ]
weeks nobody can take it away from you
nobody can go what are you you really
got a sack card it's just such and such
a son know that not dog I started as an
extra over here and I got promoted to
the [ __ ] sergeant of the movie and
ever since I got an agent I said
headshots i hand-delivered them I got
robbed of my age and he took my checks
that I quit no I [ __ ] went backwards
other agent he got me a role in this a
role and not a role in this and this is
who I am today that's what it's all
about when you get here still sticking
around yeah a lot of people [ __ ]
company and get a little success and bow
it don't work for them and they [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out it don't go their way
the developmental deal don't get picked
up that's when you get strength is when
you stay after that should happen if you
just came here for developmental deal
and left but the [ __ ] you come here
for yeah yeah I get for six [ __ ]
years to get one of those things now
seven years pick a developmental deals
we come and see you like CSUN she sounds
great it has a all Ali I like Parks and
Rec enjoy always jokes
I love gang doing work SNL I like
walking the one where my parents were
watching and I was cool I also like the
eyes there were two content specials
beautiful I'll tell you what man I'm
very happy I did on my special and they
got nicked Apollo odd yeah they got big
Jay oakerson in there
I mean would see so you get unlimited
access to see so original series that
could day length night show hilarious
stand-up specials Benjie worthy classics
including forty two seasons of San and
live the entire monthly Python collide
should the it crowd and much much more
you savages both seasons of hidden
America with Jonah ray
the debut TV series from my brother my
brother and me the McElroy brothers an
animated fantasy role-playing game
starring Dan Harmon and hilarious and
famous comedian with two guests see so
has that - no no no they're on fire guys
see so is the new home for all favorite
comedy BrickCon understanding of
specials vegetable classics and more and
it's all on demand and had three you're
like British comedy is like to hit crown
and Monty Python hell yeah
or maybe you prefer classics like the
kids and Hall and Parks and Rec like
Lisa Ann how about every episode of SNL
and late-night TV including new episodes
the day after they're about access Cecil
contents them anywhere anytime using iOS
Android Roku Amazon fire TV Apple TV
Windows and Xbox one ready for the punch
line see so it's three $9.99 a month no
joke three ninety-nine a month for the
comedy you want
Anytime Anywhere ad-free just go to see
so calm right now sign up for one month
with promo code Joey at check out that
see so calm spelled se ESO calm promo
code Joey again see so calm grumble call
Joey
check out my special Laurie kill
Martin's on say I love it
dunk Stanhope's on there it's all
beautiful right see so is a savage
number two listen Labor Day come home
alone you know when I walk
the Sun is that you go to the beat some
chick wants to see you the bikini gets
wet you got the boxer shorts on let's
pretend you taking little shorts on
you got skid marks and talking and
listening you got shot with a musket
I get those little Roush broach holes
that coming in the way you get those
you're looking in the way leg laughter
right who's the [ __ ] who's he so much
[ __ ] termite oh yes a nightmare and
yeah under way is Galu oh my god
weakened by little holes like somebody
sat there with a needle I can really
think about it every table is it's the
stink or your nutsack that comes through
the cotton opens up naturally I can't
even take it them why they all talk to
each other we're going to do with the
stink nut that this [ __ ] animal has
he just bust out anyway what I'm trying
to say D is everybody hold on the right
you don't want because the good look
good you got to feel good Jack and lost
art [ __ ]
one word me on these not being on these
is the most comfortable line of the
deliverable right to your door what is
me on these huh again seriously saw feel
good undies delivered right to your door
the engines are designed in that way and
made from our standing source micro
motor a fabric 3 times softer than
cotton me off these unders me off these
soft and soft locks on these covers
ever-changing selection of classic
colors bold shades and adventurous
patterns seams and tailor your undies to
your own personal style we take some BM
these are the coolest things out there
they can they they send you a new pair a
month all different colors polka dots
listen I look at them and I giggle but I
put them on you know why because they're
[ __ ] tremendously comfortable and
guess what you can save time and money
each one was a monthly subscription
let's pretend you not ready for a
subscription that's ok I'm going to
still save you some money that's because
the undies is offering you 20% off your
first pair
just use the special you are a Miyagi's
dot-com / Joey and got 20% off your
first pet listen you're a hard worker
you're trying to sling some dick you
want to look sharp go to Miyagi's calm
right now
/ jelly again me under you duck times
last Joey so I had revamped your
underwear drawer
you deserve it you filthy animal what
what kind of 100 comm why alpha brain it
don't work for you you don't even want
it back though singing back to Jesus
another % just sending the email say
listen I took alpha brain and I can't
stop jumping up and down that's it boom
on a.com press charge back 10% off the
Liberty house who's better than us see
you once they've [ __ ] Thank You
Jorge Perez
thank you Lisa at Oh May 25th Icehouse
8:30
I'm just working out one hour we're
trying new [ __ ] come on in it's the
weekend let's start the weekend off
right skate but I love you [ __ ]
[Music]
all right you can open that door
princess remember
big film wanna check it out on the back
damn dick in me and [ __ ] the egg eaters
damn a little city chillin in the next
Bay in the same my boys don't play fool
will preside and you know how to stop
those and the back sipping purple Jam
goes to look for trouble but it always
seems a bad forty Griffin panting second
denisita Papa Honda kick back one okay
oh here's a race to the next episode in
a saga double do Velma hold it I guess I
better tell ya it's Friday night I got a
brand new all for me to get on missus my
cousin picked up a tail
and
I'll do a backward daddy edit animal mr.
clapping starting to fly baby
what an asteroid to Maremma one nothing
is impossible to know what it means got
a [ __ ] I said a crappy rate for Danny
money back to the I gotta
could it be I just got a page in a row I
want to do me hook this Porter meet me
at the hotel she had a feeling what else
oh I caught a Lumia Sally wanted to
stick my lips
we'll try to make it real quick idea I
jumped in the air train for wait a
minute we gotta get a vein I got to get
some gum and a packet of life jackets
now we're getting full oh damn there
goes a baby
so color watch yourself down [ __ ] the
ride in a farm like this one okay you
got a bunch of take one like 918 my way
like soccer we don't worry please
I get out the right one type of the last
one got away one look at the life man I
just moved in try and let me to sing on
sign-in
beautiful this your block the mail so I
can catch something here another hotel